[Musique]
le 2 novembre une adolescente de 16 ans
est signalée comme disparue dans le
kentucky la jeune fille est retenue
prisonnière dans la voiture de son
kidnappeur dans les cendres de 17 ans
portée disparue depuis un peu plus de 24
heures a été retrouvée vivante à une
dizaine de kilomètres son domicile à sa
blessure ça
l'adolescente parvient à alerter un
automobiliste grâce à un geste de
détresse après sur le réseau social tik
tok
l'automobiliste reconnaît ce symbole et
alertes directement les autorités du
kentucky qui ont intercepté le véhicule
à la sortie d'autoroute
la jeune joggeuse a expliqué aux
enquêteurs avoir été enlevé puis
séquestré avant de réussir à échapper à
un ou plusieurs ravisseurs à battre est
clairement il est candidat d'ailleurs ce
serait bien qu'ils n'avancent pas
masqués le président de la république
finalement à utiliser les 20 millions de
français qui l'ont suivi et utilise tous
les moyens de la république pour faire
sa campagne que ce soient les moyens
financiers ou les moyens médiatiques
c'est vraiment prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles houde a parfaitement compris
qu'il était candidat il annonce des
choses qu'il faudra faire ensuite donc
tout le monde comprend que c'est après
2022 je suis atterré enfin c'est un
meeting électoral télévisé auquel
emmanuel macron nous a conviés c'est un
président qui est en campagne équidés
qui au fond instrumentalise la crise
sanitaire pour défendre ses idées
la dernière fois qu'un modèle macro et
une vague contradictions c'était face au
youtube heures mcphail carlito c'est dur
il va durer longtemps ce monologue un
discours de cruauté de brutalité avec
des mesures extrêmement dures vis-à-vis
des français qui sont dans la difficulté
je parle notamment de ceux qui sont
frappés par le chômage j'ai vu un
président de la république à la tâche au
travail est fermement déterminée à
poursuivre son action jusqu'au dernier
jour de son mandat abbas était
clairement le candidat macron
pharmaciens d'état n'a évoqué aucun
sujet
sinon la pandémie il a abordé 30 m nous
avons compté pendant qu'on l'écouté
comment voulez-vous que on puisse
ramasser une pensée critique ou un
commentaire dans des conditions
pareilles le président de république est
dans un déni incroyable que ce soit sur
le chômage le pouvoir d'achat
l'endettement de notre pays on assisté
hier soir une sorte de baratin
présidentielle très loin de la réalité
que vivent les français feraient que les
oppositions réagi c'est plutôt bon signe
moi je pense quand on est attaqué c'est
toujours très bon signe c'était quoi
cette voie si grave que mehdi s'étonne
macro et là muet ou coiffeur général la
voix d'emmanuel mâcon plus graves que
d'habitude a affolé le web et avec qui
nous fait à l'elysée la veille le
président at il lu et s'interrogent les
internautes d'autres s'amusent et s
fantômas dark vador ou bien barry white
il avait perdu sa voix vous l'avez
remarqué non il est un genre où est
enrhumé une voix plus grave qu'à
l'accoutumée effectivement j'ai vu que
ça faisait beaucoup de débats sur les
réseaux sociaux nous n'avons
malheureusement pas fini avec la crise
sanitaire les signaux d'alert se
multiplient se confirme et s'amplifie
l'europe vit actuellement une reprise
économique le net le président de la
république vu l'augmentation du taux
d'incidence l'hiver arrive et le cirque
le virus circule plus bas nous demander
de demander au préfet aux policiers aux
gendarmes de contrôler davantage comme
avant comme en septembre et ce matin une
instruction part au préfet et je les
réunis bientôt pour pouvoir appliquer
ces deux mondes et bracelets de
marie-antoinette vendu pour plus de 7
millions d'euros c'est la première fois
que ces bracelets de des pousses de
louis saez composé au total de 112
diamant été mis aux enchères et envie
d'une bonne douche je pense aux
premièrement des nourritures terrestres
avec une bonne nuit dans un bon lit un
café un petit déjeuner et puis ensuite
tu as far se remettre au boulot vous
risquez la radiation
je sais pas ce que je risque honnête
quand ça fait partie du panel de son jeu
à peine de mort ce n'est pas mal